over the last month or so millions of
graduating high school students made a
decision on where to go to college and
in so doing most will also go deep into
debt there are more than 44 million
borrowers out there with student loan
debt in the u.s. now totaling more than
1.5 trillion with the T dollars that's
more than what Americans owe in credit
cards auto financing or home equity
loans now some presidential candidates
are proposing solutions to fix the
worsening debt problem Atlantic writer
Derek Thompson is here to talk about it
Derek good morning good morning and we
know the numbers are astounding just in
saying that why are we going political
with this why are the candidates getting
in on this well number one because the
numbers are astounding 1.5 trillion in
debt 44 million people this is not a
niche issue I also think there's a bit
of demand and supply here demand among
the millennial generation the largest
generation in American history they're
voting more in a few years they're going
to be the biggest voting segment in the
American electorate so issues that
matter to them are gonna come to the
fore then you have supply I think
there's been an attitudinal shift among
people running for president to say
we're not going to think about policies
in a technocratic way about tweaking
something over here tweaking something
over here we're all about making huge
big statements about who we are we're
going to have a green new deal we're
going to break up the monopolies we're
gonna make college tuition free and
eliminate student debt that's the new
style do that and though the
affordability issue I mean you're saying
that they have gone and they've targeted
it in this manner
what's the overall hope that comes out
of some of these plans to make college
truly more affordable well let's look at
the plan specifically you have Bernie
Sanders who has said for years now
really has been leading the charge to
make public education in the United
States entirely debt-free that has been
his big calling card on education
Elizabeth Warren is going one step
further she's saying we should eliminate
student debt for all a merry for million
Americans up to $50,000 that would
essentially eliminate student debt for
95 percent of Americans who have it
those who over $50,000 often tend to be
in graduate programs like law school or
medical
school they tend to earn more after they
graduate from these programs so both of
these policies would be absolutely
mammoth attempts yes restructure the way
that we educate Americans in the way
that Americans pay for that education
the Warren the Warren Plan would would
essentially pay for that with an ultra
millionaires tax correct yes she would I
mean there's not all of these plans have
paid for us but Elizabeth Warren has
been careful to at least offer some way
at thank for this plans which she said
essentially as look this is going to
cost maybe up to a trillion dollars yeah
where are you gonna find a trillion
risers you're gonna find them among
people who earn a hundred million
dollars or a billion dollars just for a
second let's talk about the significance
of this overall debt because it is I
mean it is it's bigger than credit card
debt only mortgage debt is bigger than
it yeah the average graduate at the
class of 2017 owes upwards of $28,000
it's absolutely extraordinary and this
is a huge change Americans didn't use to
have all the student debt it's a it's
like tripled in the last ten years and
it's because of one very simple thing
public education used to be funded
publicly states used to spend a lot more
money on public education as they spent
less families spent more but
middle-income families couldn't
necessarily afford it and so they had to
go into debt to send their kids to
college real quickly Derek I mean we're
talking about candidates on the
Democratic side anything from the White
House along these lines because right
now there's a Republican in the White
House yes so the White House has not
made this issue a priority they've
issued a white paper that says we're
interested in finding ways to make it
easier for people to consolidate their
student debt pay it off over time and
will forgive it if they make on-time
payments for more than 15 years at the
same time the Education Department
itself has rolled back some Obama
policies that made it more difficult for
for-profit colleges to essentially screw
their students out of their education to
lard them up with debt and then graduate
them with an education that didn't give
them a lot in the labor force so they're
sort of giving and taking at the same
time and those percentage rates that's
the big issue yes exactly you wonder
what you want to do is to find a way to
mandate that people pay a low percentage
of their income over time and then after
a certain amount of time eliminated that
or used to eliminate the debt entire
affects almost everybody out there Derek
thank you very much thank you